Some of it's just not,
you can be friends with people that you don't agree.
I,
me and Nick Depaulo disagree with like 75% of shit.
I love the guy.
I always love hanging out with them.
I've known him forever.
I never,
never like never do I say God's nick again.
I love it when he gets mad about shit.
Damn.
Well what?
You don't know what fucking Obama deck?
Yeah,
it's great.
He's on,
he's on that a cameo website and you can just pay him to trash your liberal
friends.
Oh,
that's fun.
It's so fucking funny.
And he'll just like,
it was like,
what do you like fucking Hillary?
You fucking faggot
in his kitchen.
Yeah,
it's fucking great life.
Beat her on.
Yeah.
Um,
but I look Patrice,
you know,
I remember I,
I watch my son,
my son's mother was in labor for 30 hours,
fucking crazy long labor overnight and the next morning she's like lying down.
He's like in the little fucking other room or whatever.
And I'm watching like a fan made Patrice O'Neal documentary and he's just saying
like the most heinous shit about how women aren't shit and about how fucking a
bitch,
you know,
she needs you.
And by,
and I just watched my son's mother pushed my son out of her for 30 hours.
It was fucking,
I mean the,
the whole experience was so mind blowing and in my mind I'm going,
I could never in a million years do what she just did.
I had this whole other appreciation for what a woman is.
It's like a,
it blows your mind when you got kids and then Patrice is fuck it up.
They're just this big fat black guy saying horseshit cause he,
he's fucking,
but it's the funniest shit on the planet.
The absolute funny shit on the planet and you can laugh at it.
You don't have to get mad at,
I don't agree with half the shittiest,
most of the shit that he says.
All that fucking Aye.
Look Dude,
I'm an idiot.
I don't look at,
I don't,
I don't go after women that are below me.
I like to go after women that are above me and that sort of elevate me and make
me want to be better.
I think that's,
it's a little check and balance system.
I have him for myself,
you know?
Um,
but you don't have to be so connected to whatever the messages,
you can literally take it for face value,
which is,
it's just really funny.
Like undeniable
funny.
Yeah.
He was a monster and he also,
he had points,
really good psychological insight.
He knew what made people tick.
He knew what made people say stupid shit.
He knew it made people stumble.
He's a,
he was a master at understanding like how to get off controversial ideas.
Yeah.
You know,
he was in,
but his,
his contribution for a lot of us was a,
he had an extra level of,
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
like you would see don roasts.
He would,
he'd,
you know,
he'd roast and he was like,
yeah,
I don't even know why I'm up here.
You want me to be,
or even on my level.
Yeah.
It was Charlie Sheen.
Yes.
Yeah.
Charlie Sheen rose again.
He just went off script through the paper and was just,
that was brilliant.
Chartered.
He's a killer man.
Did that one,
cause he,
I guess he agreed because he said that was the only guy that he was interested
in roasting.
I like,
I'm not doing it for the paycheck.
Charlie Sheen's a fucking g.
Yeah.
Um,
well it's just that he's,
you know,
he would,
he just had this don't give a fuck style.
Yeah.
And we all,
like,
we all,
I think I can be speaking
for myself.
I appreciate,
I don't give a fuck style more than any other style of comedy.
For me,
my favorite shit was like,
first of all,
Joey Diaz,
but then when you go back to the greats,
like Kinison and Hicks and this guys didn't give a fuck.
They went out,
they went off and it was the most fun to watch as a person who was a,
an audience member for me was the most fun to watch.
And I think,
you know,
that's,
that's the shit that I got.
And it's,
yeah,
we grew up on that and then society changes.
And I'm like,
no dude,
I've been,
I've been working on this for so long,
please let me,
I have to change my entire like foundation of what I think is funny now because
it's almost like,
and that's why I think guys like Legion of skanks and,
and the specialist,
you guys name it,
Legion of Skanks,
me and big J.
Okay.
So big Jay would constantly cheat on his wife and uh,
it was like a regular occurrence and she knew it and everyone knew it.
And one time we were there and we were hanging out and we were about to leave.
They were in an argument and she's like,
fuck you,
why don't you go,
hey,
how was your legion of skanks and me and big j,
we were both playing guitar hero at the time.
There was like a big game.
We both looked at each other.
We're like guitar hero name.
And that was what we named our band initially.
And Guitar Hero was Legion of skanks and then we're not that creative.
So we wrote a script.
How long ago was this?
Probably 10 years ago.
10 years ago.
The name.
And then that was the guitar hero band.
Maybe even more.
Probably more.
Yeah.
Actually way more.
Cause it was right with me in big Jay became friends.
Um,
and then we wrote,
yeah,
Legion of skanks is a great name.
It's probably one of the all time greatest names of anything.
Right.
You stop and think about like bands or television,
legion of skanks.
That is a great thank you.
Thank you,
Joe.
Great Name.
Yeah.
Well I've got to give it a big Jack because he recognized it immediately.
And then every project we ever did since then has been named Legion of skanks
until the podcast work.
It's good.
Move.